soon bismillah al hamdulillah assalamu
alaykum which is a greeting of peace
peace be unto you thank you you can find
us here every week thank you for tuning
in you don't catch us on the local cable
station here in Chicago you can see all
of our shows at the Dean show calm we're
here trying to help you develop a better
understanding on the world's fastest
growing way of life the way of life of
all the messengers of God the way of
surrender and submission to the One God
worshipping Him alone and not his
creation now we come back we're going to
be trying to answer and clear up the fog
helping you understand Islam a little
better by answering your common
questions that you might have on this
beautiful way of life we come back here
on the Dean show you don't want to go
nowhere Allah there's only one but a
Muhammad is His Messenger a la la
o Allah there's only one but Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice
assalamualaikum well I think when we
said how Allah hear what I catch please
be unto you peace be unto you as well
how are you I'm doing fine and Hamdi
this greeting that we just said to each
other was this a greeting of all the
messengers of God it was indeed it was
indeed and in fact this is something
that cannot be denied historically as
well it's what's well documented that
even priests and rabbis would greet one
another with the greetings of peace in
fact to this day I believe priests greet
each other with pax vobiscum in Latin
which basically means peace be unto you
so it's it's well known it's something
that all the prophets of god used to
grew another in fact beautiful story we
have in our tradition that when God
created Adam yeah and he told Adam to go
to the Angels he told Adam when you when
you come to them then say assalamu
alaykum to them say peace be unto you
and hear what they say back and so when
he said that to them the angel said
walaikum assalaam so in fact the very
first conversation that took place
embodied may peace be unto you that's a
beautiful greeting it is be it is indeed
I think it's better than hey what's up
and how you doing are you doing it
breaks the ice it doesn't it does it
yeah it shows you that you care about
the person that you're genuinely
concerned about him he shows you you're
not going to harm him you want good for
him from him for yourself and you're
praying to God to lessen as well yeah
and this is a one of the common
questions that we're going to be
answering today why do you guys say
assalamu alaikum and we just answer that
so moving on to the next because there's
a lot of common questions that people
are interested and this is the fastest
growing way of life and people
understand that we don't worship a black
box in the desert we don't pray to
mohammed mohammed is the last and final
messenger peace be upon him and all the
messages got including Jesus Christ who
is one of the mightiest messages of God
but besides that there's some other
questions we're going to try to go
through these they asked what I'm here
for they asked us why don't we drink
alcohol why don't we drink alcohol well
the simple answer is because God told us
to that's the
simplest answer which is a foolproof
answer we believe that God knows best
and why whatever he tells us we do it
now does that mean where we have blind
faith yes and no yes because we believe
that whatever God says we need to do it
but no in that we first rationally come
to the conclusion that this is a true
God who has sent us this book that is
something we need to think about so we
don't expect people to just accept Islam
because we tell them to we want people
to critically think and challenge
themselves and think about the fact is
this the true religion or not is this a
true prophet or not is this a true book
of God or not once they answer yes to
all of these questions that's rational
they look at the life of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him they look at
the teachings of the Quran they look at
overall what this religion says and then
they rationally intellectually
understand this to be the truth they say
yes this is the religion once they
accept now you can't really question
eating everything why do you pray five
times a set of six yeah why is this
allowed and that not well I mean there
are always answers but the simplest
answer like I said foolproof God knows
best we send so now that's the first
answer and that's the best answer there
are also of course other answers as well
then the Quran tells us that the Quran
very clearly says about alcoholic drinks
and by the way it's not just alcohol in
our times drugs anything that
intoxicates the mind that makes a person
marijuana everything marijuana coke
crack achieving everything is out in any
of these things are severely prohibited
in our religion because I heard
somewhere some people actually say that
it doesn't say now you can either these
are these are Muslims trying to justify
their no scholar says there's no
reputable legal authority says this and
of course God says so in the corn bread
quite clearly that there is some benefit
in alcohol yeah nobody denies this those
are drinking I mean you know there is
some benefit enough but God says the
evil is much more than the benefit the
harm is more than the good and so the
harm that's caused by alcohol is much
more and I think any government in the
world especially our Western governments
know this very well the number of
accidents number of homicides number of
crimes that occur under the influence
right are much more than
than the other crimes and this is
something that is well known from
experiences while living in any land
where people drink public and openly
look at what happens when people get
drunk and look at the amount of of
crimes that are committed in the name of
let's say drugs trying to get drugs
right tryna to you people will will
literally sell their own kids in order
to get those drugs we see this in front
of us so God says in the Quran there
might be some benefit you might get high
but the harm is greater than and we
should ban it we see that all around see
murder ray exactly and yeah most of the
people are are under the influence yeah
exactly you mentioned the government
didn't the government try to ban alcohol
at one point it did and it goes to show
you that man-made laws are always gonna
be you know trying to be fine-tuned and
tinkered with and that's why we believe
as Muslims that the law of God is
perfect because it doesn't need to be
changed and tinkered with yeah another
common question is why do you put these
women behind the veil why do you have
them come okay once again there's the
easy response and then there's more
complicated when the easy response of
course God says so that's it I mean once
we say that they really can't you know
there's nothing that to be said it's
quite clear the Quran very explicitly
commands and it's not just women by the
way this is a common misconception how
come women have to cover men have to
cover but to a lesser extent yeah right
men can't go around naked men have to
cover between the navel to the knee they
can't just go around you know wearing
tight shorts even as a Muslim there is a
sense of modesty so there's restrictions
not just on women there's restrictions
on men as well and that's many people
just overlook that and it's jump to the
women's side now there's no doubt that
women have more coverings on them and I
think that even in Western society you
know you go to the beach women are
wearing two-piece and men are wearing
one piece okay even even where there's
not that much modesty but still more is
covered for the women with the fur the
man and that's the way God created man
and women that the body of the woman is
far more attractive to the man than vice
versa therefore God in His wisdom and
this is the second point god I the first
point is God says so that's why the
second point it's obvious that the body
of a woman is far more abused and
misused if you look at modern media if
you look at advertising if you look at
the point industry right what is it is
only its filth it's taking advantage of
men's animal instincts and desires at
the expense of woman's chastity and
honor and so our religion has come and
said no you can't do that you can't do
that at all you can't take it
vantage of a woman and exposure like
that you know Denny crater to this level
we believe that these types of things
are are far more this is this is
denigrating women this is taking
advantage of women and so our religion
has come and said no women have to have
modesty and so do men now of course in
the privacy of their houses couples can
do as they please that's the only time
it's allowed you're allowed to see your
spouse and to enjoy your spouse that's
what marriage is for within the confines
of marriage outside of marriage all of
this needs to be minimized and avoided
and of the ways we minimize it is that
we ask men and women to dress modestly
and modesty is different between the
genders but for the women modesty is
defined as covering of the hair at least
and wearing loose clothing and of course
the you know the finer details vary from
culture to time a place but overall the
primary condition is loose clothing and
the body covered including the hair and
that's why they wear a headscarf over
their heads now this is interesting
because if you come at it from just as
you said the crater said so we're not
making her the man's not making her but
the crater told her to do and she is
submitting to exact the injunctions of
the crater as the man is as well yeah
exactly and you also have you have
certain restaurants you just can't come
in without shoes or you can't come
inside shirt no shoes no shirt no
service that's what it says you can't go
into the courthouse uh-uh you any way
that you want once upon a time you
couldn't even wear your cap in front of
the judges and that's all these are
man-made injunctions exactly have they
follow exactly but the crater knows best
how much needs to be now let me you know
we live in America yeah in America and
the majority of states nudity is a
punishable offense yeah the state
imposes a restriction on clothing right
you cannot walk the streets of Chicago
or you know I don't know the laws of a
little bit I'd assume you know you can
yeah you know I'm in most states you
cannot walk the streets naked you will
be punished jailed fine so the fact of
the matter is that society is
restricting what you wear our religion
has a permanent restriction what you can
do today you couldn't do 10 years ago
which you could attend use you couldn't
do 100 years ago a hundred years ago no
respectable woman would leave her house
without her hair cover in this country
this is in America
every woman would have her hair covered
with the bondage she wear loose clothing
she wouldn't wear a mini skirt or
anything like that this is on reducible
these are our own great-grandmother's
you know every we are from the earth so
we see evolution of morals in man-made
society we believe that our
great-grandmother's and us are at our
generation we're the same human beings
we believe what was good for them should
be good for us we eat the same food we
drink the same water we read the same
air we're still the same human beings
even if you've gone to the moon and back
hard morality should remain the same
yeah and so I think it makes a lot of
sense when our religion tells us these
are restrictions that are eternal they
don't change from time to place decided
it's not an amendment that you know is
cancelled because it's not enforceable
and it doesn't work that way it's that's
I think it I think it makes a lot of
articles ends and they should talk to
these women the women who have submitted
to the Creator and they have chosen to
not be slaves to the fashion to society
to a man but to the crater that they're
truly free isn't it exactly i mean i
encourage you if you see a lady wearing
the scarf of muslin lady with all
respect obvious on intimidation just ask
her politely as anybody forcing you to
do this or do you want to do this on
your own in fact i mean i know i'm a bit
of a cleric as you know I'm involved
with giving lectures and speeches and
seminars I'll tell you the main problem
that I hear is that these women their
parents are trying to force them not to
wear the scarf that's the problem that's
the problem that that you know the
parents are so scared it's not that they
hate the religion it's just they're
scared that Americans the broad society
is going to harm them they're scared
that somebody's going to go in and you
know pusher or Shover or you know worse
than this so they don't want their
daughters to where the scar this is a
legitimate excuse now not to wear the
heck up if there's a genuine fear than
yes but I would say by and large I mean
we are all Americans here I'd say by and
large we are a tolerant society and
maybe there might be a few comments here
and there but by and large I mean
there's not a threat to life and limb
now that's the case right now but there
are places in the world where sometimes
you know being identified as whatever
means always sometimes the Jews were
harassed sometimes you know the the
African Americans were has sometimes
Mexicans you know as there are places
where if you're a Muslim it might be
dangerous to show that and so obviously
in such a circumstance there's laxity
but I would say by and large in North
America we are enjoying great
amounts of freedom and we need to we
need to make sure that people know our
faith and we're proud to be who we are
and also be proud to be ethnically and
culturally and nationally we are as well
there's no there's no contradiction
being an American white person or a
black person or Muslim are all they're
all compatible together now these are
some of the common questions which we
can encourage you to go to the Dean show
calm where we actually have a site on
the site for new Muslims and we address
these questions even more extensively we
are moving on along to the next common
question with my good friend [ __ ] yasir
Qadhi people ask they say well you know
how is it that the crater allows a man
in Islam to have more than one wife how
is this how can this be something they
envision now the man with a harem of
women will be right back no speech is
better than to do that was call people
to Allah and to do there were no
speeches better no nothing is better
than that is it true that if one person
I'm the how law giving you an ability to
guide so much the lost permission the
greatest permission that was better than
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be giving out
giving down and this is something that
we encourage all the MSAs all the dowel
organizations the musjid forget this we
want to print more we give these to the
non mrs. for free for free for free we
want our brothers it
and how do we explain how do you are
going to this well well Eddie this is
definitely a question that a lot of
Muslims get asked and it raises a lot of
eyebrows and there's a lot of
stereotypes attached to it and there's
no doubt that culturally speaking it is
problematic for many people to
understand and envision but it's true
that our religion has allowed a man to
marry more than one woman I but it's not
just our religion I mean this is a
well-known fact that many cultures and
many societies and in fact to this day
there are many countries where this is
legal not necessarily Muslim countries I
was in South Africa last week and their
president has I think three wives yeah
and and this is and this is this is
president of South Africa which is a
very modern western country that you
said why is not girlfriends oh no no
yeah that's the whole point that because
some residents we know have had
girlfriends this is most presidents the
moat world oh yes yeah so what our
religion does and this is it's really
logical is that if you know it's
possible and capable and everybody's is
you know is fine with it then it is
permissible for a man to take on more
than one woman with certain conditions
this is what our religion has said and
once again it's not a necessary
requirement it's just an option and
contrary to popular opinion the vast
majority of Muslims have one wife and
that's the way things are and they're
all over the Muslim world you know i
would say off the top of my head maybe
ninety ninety-five percent all over the
Muslim world the vast majority basically
11 wife or husband everything's fine now
our religion does allow for a husband to
take on more than one wife but we're the
only religion that has so many
conditions attached to it now in other
societies and cultures there are no
conditions take as many as you want and
treat them as you will in our religion
if any man you know if is legal for him
to do so if he chooses to take on
another wife there are many stringent
conditions attached of them as equality
of them is the fact that you know he
must give them you know similar amounts
of time of them is that is that he must
be capable of taking care of them you
know he can't just take on a mistress or
girlfriend and then just say you know
you're my wife is that he's got to take
care of them all of these are understood
that the husband is going to take care
of all of his wives and all of his
children equally
and that's a condition that i think is
once you get a very logical condition
this is something that today in today's
society what is normal today was in
normal yesterday gangs that are
constantly changing according to maybe
the people's desires but if we look back
a little bit this was something that was
normal wasn't it yes for most societies
and cultures around the world it was
indeed normal even as every Christian in
junos even in biblical times the average
person had more than one wife and that's
because of the circumstances situations
that they that they went through I mean
most of the prophets of God in the Bible
had more than one wife and so I mean
again like I said if a person finds this
you know culturally he doesn't want to
do it sure go ahead Don dream it's not
necessary to not at all you're not any
better muslim if you have two wives or
not your your Islam is not affected you
don't have to it's not even necessarily
encourage or discourage it's a neutral
thing if you want to and there's a
legitimate you no reason and cause and
you are justified in and making sure
you're going to take care of them all
equally it's an option that is available
if circumstances are appropriate if a
person doesn't want to then that's
completely permissible as well now if we
even go rationally because we're trying
to solve problems of the world who would
know best how to solve these problems a
crater that happens in a way exactly
yeah if you just think about it you know
there's an excess of women there are
there some say the Census Bureau that
you have 10 million single mothers out
there you have nearly 700,000 woman who
lose their husbands each year's men in
jail some are leaning towards other men
was called homosexuality out and now how
do you solve this you have orphans 12
million orphans women out there without
husband so what's the solution to this
how is it that we solve this problem
yeah exactly this is the whole point is
that if you want to talk about
justifications we can go on and on and
on and show that this is something that
biologically psychologically there are a
lot of positives now of course there are
some negatives as well nobody's denying
that they are there nothing is one
hundred percent perfect in any situation
in Scenario there's no doubt that
there's some issues involved as well you
know about taking another wife but what
we would argue is that theoretically
speaking this would provide farmers
solutions and be better for society this
is what what our religion would say is
that this is something that would bring
about far greater good than any
negatives that might possibly come about
because of that and as you said the
statistics are quite clear I think every
country really is facing this problem
and men by nature they abused women much
more sexually they just go and have a
relationship then move on to another one
our religion prohibits that and says if
you want to have a relationship you
better take care of the consequences you
better take care of her as a human being
love her treat her with respect and
dignity publicly and now she's your wife
and the kids are your kids so there's a
lot of psychological factors that yeah
it does make a lot of sense and in fact
I mean uh I'm just saying that's not
really to the religion politically
speaking in now with the legality of
homosexuality pretty much you know
legality meaning in terms of modern
American laws is becoming more and more
common and legal in many states I'm from
Connecticut in the Connecticut they've
already passed the bill the next wave is
quite clearly going to be a polygamy it
is yes i have i have read a number of
articles that are out there is an
article out on the law and society
journal of love was last month or
something where the non-muslim and
nothing to do with islam is basically
saying look if you're going to remove
restrictions you need to remove all
restrictions huh and therefore if a
person wants to marry more than one
person they're all agreeing and happy
with it what if the government's
allowing two men to get married right
why shouldn't it allow a man to get
right that doesn't make any does it make
and I mean it's at all for the true
seeker the one who is humble and he
wants to do with the Creator taupe even
if he's not now at that stage but you
know he's just using a good old common
sense he's not being someone who's just
looking for trouble mm-hmm this makes
sense now there are some people that are
pointing the finger but they don't
understand it's four point back at them
so you you'll see televangelist people
who are out there you know they'll try
to make fun of the Muslim but then
you'll switch the channel and you hear
people like the Jimmy Swaggart and the
morrow Jimmy bakers and etc etc and the
list we can bring them and they'll fill
this whole paper and page and then be on
prostitutes they're caught with several
of them this is hypocritical isn't it is
it is and it's a very major problem and
of course I mean we're not denying that
this doesn't occur in our own religion
as well of course there are Muslim
who also fall into these things you know
we've had we've had cases in our culture
we have case in other cultures but the
thing that we're arguing for at least
our religion provides a very good
solution yeah that's what we're arguing
for nobody's perfect you know you know
Christian priests have the Roman
Catholic Church has a major scandal now
of course you can point fingers at every
culture I'm sure Jewish rabbis I'm sure
Muslim Imams would also maybe there's
some molestations going on as well but
the fact of the matter is that Jews and
Muslims have an alternative you can't
expect a human being to dedicate himself
to God and not have any desires we would
say this is an unnatural state of
affairs where you tell this man do not
get married you're not allowed to get
married we would say it's inevitable
that there's going to be a preponderance
of promiscuity and and and molestation
amongst those people now pointing
fingers like you said it's easy to do
the point is we have a solution yeah and
that solution does make a lot of sense
and I mean is only a matter of time like
I said they're already many people
arguing the case and as you know uh
certain factions of the Mormon trick not
the mainstream Oh judge but there's a
faction of the Mormon Church that very
publicly engages in in in in polygyny
which is one man marry more than one
husband by the way polygamy is too broad
because polygamy means pleasure me yeah
it's polygyny is the more precisely
polygamy means plurality of spouses so
you can have one man with many wise so
you can have one woman with many
husbands yeah our religion and also this
version of the Mormon religion it only
allows polygyny which is one man with
more than one woman now of course the
Mormons allow unlimited wives we have a
restriction that's a maximum of four so
the point is there's a wave now starting
here in America to to legalize polygyny
uh and uh it's a matter of time I mean
Muslims are really well with this way by
the way yet but it's only a matter of
time because we get on board us I I
don't have a comment about whether we
should or not because it's happening
anyway yeah there are people who argue
are the paper that i read it was written
by somebody who's actually secularist
he's nothing to with the religion but
he's simply saying look if a person
wants to take care of another woman and
her children and you know be responsible
it's better for society to legalize it
that's a very common sense you know
person you said something take care of
her her her children or her herself just
give her her rights because now i think
it's easier
that man let's say who wants to have a
little mistress on the side you can give
her some money here go buy some clothes
and I'll give you a call when I need you
exactly at then it might be a thrill for
her but at a lower in the long run it's
harmful she's actually they use the good
words like girlfriend and mistress but
it's kind of like a concubine isn't it
it is it does mean sir let's be quite
plant yeah she has no benefits no
stability and she knows she's going to
be dropped as soon as you know he's
fulfilled with her and moves on to a
younger girl or something or as in a
marriage is a lot more stability and its
public and of course even if a marriage
ends in a divorce it's a respectable
institution we're okay didn't work out a
divorce happen you know it's not a
girlfriend on the side that she's just
changing there's an element of respect
and dignity with the marriage even if it
ends in failure not all marriages work
out so the point is that it legitimizes
a human need and relationship and it
makes something which is very beautiful
it makes it legitimate and pure whereas
promiscuity and and and prostitution
make something that's very beautiful it
makes it ugly and cheap that's the
difference this is amazing because this
is for me and I'm sure for any true
seeker and the Muslim this is something
that is just another proof that this is
the true from the Creator it covers
every aspect of life exactly it gives
you an option when you need it and if
you don't need it then you don't need to
take the option because I mean the three
candidates that were running for
president I mean if they would have done
this if it was allowed they wouldn't
have to go on behind the woman's back
and commits something that is most
preposterous exact commit infidelity
exactly this is something that we are
running away from we don't want
girlfriends we want wise because we care
from take care of them give them their
rights not treat them like a concubine
or a woman who is just here fly-by-night
that's the whole point it gives you
respect and legitimacy they did a survey
I was listening to one individual who
was talking about they had surveyed some
of these women that were the second or
maybe the third for it doesn't have like
a limit you could be like the temp
mistress they said if you had a if you
could be a second wife to take that role
on or continue just being like this you
know sidekick what would you do almost
all of them said they I
exactly and the point is all voluntary I
mean nobody's forcing any woman if a
woman wants to be in a relationship that
where she's a second or third wife then
legally speaking of we need to really
redefine if we're gonna allow to meant
to be together why can't we allow no two
women who want to be married to the same
again it's all it's up to the women is
nobody forcing it on her if she wants to
and he's willing to take on the
responsibility then really it does make
a lot of sense to argue for it legally
yeah okay so with that said we're going
to just couple a cover a couple more
points there's a lot more common
questions that we don't have time to
answer here today on Dean show you can
visit the dinosaur com go under the
non-muslim section we have a whole list
of array of questions that are commonly
asked tell us in general some of these
questions about pork somebody's question
about the veil we covered some of the
questions about do muslims worship the
black box in the desert and other
questions how can you just give a
general summary to someone who is
seeking the true but they might come
across these smaller issues yeah well
let me let me summarize for the muslim
of allama when the muslim is asked about
these issues I think if he's if Muslim
is asked about the legal commandments of
Islam the best thing to say simply well
because god said so that's why we do it
yeah if you start trying to rationalize
you're gonna just say well why this why
that how about if you sanitize pork why
can't you ate it then you know if we
just make sure there's no germs in port
you know you're always going to have you
know issues you just say look God said
so so if it's a legal issue they move it
back to the theology god said so and I
believe this is from God now why do I
would leave this from God you move into
theology you move into belief and the
Quran and the prophet muhammad saw said
that if a non-muslim is interested well
then again my response would be similar
and that is the mind you shae of legal
rulings sometimes will be beyond our
understanding like i said why do we pray
five times a day why is our charity 2.5%
and not ten percent or six percent I
don't have necessarily proper responses
for that so instead of thinking about
the mine you Shea rather look at the
broader picture and think is this a
religion from God or not and also think
should a religion that is truly from God
tell you how to live your life or not
because that's a big difference in
Christianity and Islam right by and
large Chris
don't really have what we call law they
don't have a sharia okay so I think this
is a logical question to ask yourself if
God exists and he does if God sends
prophets and he does if God reveals
books and he does should he not tell me
how to live my life doesn't that make
sense and therefore God should have a
divine code which is which can be fine
tuned for each society but there's gotta
be a general code that's exactly what
our show you is it's a general code and
we can fine tune it to each and every
society that's exactly what I'm sure he
is sure that means Sharia means the
legal system is the way legal system
well yeah I mean it actually means the
way to God which and its technical
meaning is the legal system that we
believe in thank you very much for being
with us again I didn't show may God
Almighty the Creator Allah rewards you I
mean and you as well thank you and if
you'd like to get more information on
these common questions and even for the
Muslims you should know how to answer
these basic questions go to the Dean
show com look under new Muslims and look
under common questions ass and you'll
have some good responses and hopefully
you might even have a colleague or a
friend who will come to the realization
that yes there is a creator it's
something that is in your very nature
and you know what you're ready to submit
to that one god you're ready to do what
he wants you to do because he knows best
and you know what you're going to die
one day and you want to go back to the
crater with him pleased with you and the
best way to do that is to do what he
wants you to do so come back here every
week for a new show and until next time
assalamu alaikum peace be unto you I
came from a science major when you look
at the Bible says the earth has four
corners the is that's wrong if any
Christian can point out a single
unaccomplished issue a single
unambiguous treatment where GAF GAF
peace be upon him says say that I am God
always worshipped me a matrix of
Christianity
whoo it's cold it's Leigh everybody
sleeping I arise and ask a lot of
thinking me Omar you see all are you
know all the sins I do I turn to you to
figure my sing tomorrow I'm seen for
slave you don't my love alone I'm the
one runs away oh the guide me